Recently, when I take my clear digest, I get a burning sensation.
Is it because I am low in HDL or have adequate HDL?
So, if you're taking your clear digest right before your meal and you get a burning sensation,
and you put something in, then you eat something, then you're okay.
Wherever you only take clear digest when you're eating.
So, if you're taking clear digest, I'm like empty stomach with nothing,
your stomach, you can't get a burning sensation.
Now, that's typically a sign of stomach dysfunction,
and you may want to add some support, like GI soothe to help heal your stomach line.
But really, before I would do that, I would just, you know, when you're going to take it,
when you're going to eat, I would eat a couple bites of food, take my clear digest,
and then just keep eating.
It may just because you're taking it on an empty stomach,
and it's irritating because you don't have anything in your stomach,
and then when you eat.
So, I would just take it more mid meal.
It would be more appropriate.
And if you're still having an issue, mid meal,
then you probably have some a little bit HDL,
H-PY-LORI void on.
Look at my blog post on Helical Bacter PY-LORI,
and how to treat that, and hypochloridory, and how to treat that,
because if a person has stomach problems in pain when they take HDL,
then they have to take a step back and use,
so like a GI soothe to help heal the stomach,
and instead of HDL, you have to take a step back and use apple cider vinegar
as your acidifier.
But it's probably just because you're taking an empty stomach,
so before I would do that, I would just eat something,
eat a couple bites of food, then take your product, and then keep eating.